so trump had a rally in iowa over the
weekend
we looked at the things that trump
himself said and it was completely out
of this world bonkers trump still
getting support from iowa republicans
chuck grassley was there so were others
what about the people that go to the
rally because without them trump is just
a guy speaking into a microphone
really really great stuff from ron
phillipkowski
cataloging and covering the rally goers
so let's just go through some of these
and you're going to see
really again what we're up against here
is jane jane
says she decided to move
from alaska to iowa
when she heard trump would be there this
is crazy take a listen
i found out about the rally before i
moved so that was part of the incentive
for moving as well it's my first rally
president trump made someone move to
iowa to go to one of his rallies by the
way this young lady wearing a socialism
sucks hat
there's no socialism in the united
states but socialism sucks as her hat
right
what excites you the most about
president trump oh my gosh everything he
tells everything straight as it is no
lies no bs nothing and that's what this
country needs absolutely no political
correctness and all of that no lies okay
what how do you how i mean
how
how
this this is the most dishonest
president we've ever seen and part of
what appeals to her is trump tells it
like it is and he doesn't lie she also
moved
because trump did a rally i considered
moving actually to louisiana once when
billy joel played i heard billy joel was
playing a concert there and i was like i
should really move there that makes
sense okay here's another woman
who explains that her family hates trump
and she breaks down crying this is
really something to see
i know my whole family has turned
liberal and i don't know what happened
because i didn't raise him that way and
they've all been brainwashed to think
that he's the most horrible man ever
when he's saving everyone
right i mean i'm going to start getting
emotional because
everything depends on this america
depends on this we have got to save
we've got to do everything we can
this is and i'm not even an american
citizen i was born in england but i've
been here so much
that i don't know why i find that extra
funny after the crying i'm not even an
american citizen but she lives here okay
five and this is my home
and we've got to save it we've just got
to
go but that means that she doesn't even
vote which is interesting that's in the
the
god wins in the end right that's why the
enemy is lashing out right now we know
we know we're going to suffer for a
while but it's going to be good it's
going to be more glorious than anything
we've ever seen and you understand i
mean the guy introduces the full
religious thing
but then she she talks about this idea
we're going to suffer in the short run
it's all uh
this kind of christian dominionism
extreme ideology have to have faith in
god and pray and do everything we can
everything yeah absolutely we will we
will i mean just keep the faith i do i
have complete faith that this man is
going to save us he's going to basically
saving the world not just us everyone
everyone and i just can't wait until i'm
never going to say i told you so but i'm
just going to be just so happy and
i don't know what else to say my husband
was a united states marine and he died
from agent orange from his time in
vietnam and i'm alone
so um i mean that's
you know at least her family figured out
that they shouldn't support trump that's
that's good it shows us that even within
families some people can ultimately see
reason that's good
um here's another woman who explains
that during obama christians were
persecuted
but then trump came in
and then they had freedom of religion
and trump is like the most christian
president ever which is just so not
factually accurate why is it that you
support president trump so much oh it's
it's it's just it's just heartbreaking
what's going on in our country right now
when president trump okay when we when
we were in obama you know like as a
christian we've been persecuted a lot
you know that's not true
and then when president trump
came then
all our rights are back you know we
there were no rights that were
re-established for christians under
trump
freedom
of religion
you always had it it's in the
constitution everything you know we
we're free you know president trump is
the most christian pro-christian most
pro-israel trump may actually be an
atheist
it's actually shocking how non-religious
trump has bamboozled so many people into
thinking he's a christian pro-life you
know and all that pro-life he claims at
68 he he became pro-life all his
policies are amazing you know like
he really thought as to how to become
patriot
you know so and to love this country so
yeah so we
we were really
you know glad for him we're grateful for
him and now what's going on with the
communism all the mandates there's no
communism
you know we're like being strangled you
know that our freedom is being stolen
from us so it's really you know and all
now of course this is like a perfect
example if you actually ask her
give an example of a freedom you've lost
in the last um nine months under joe
biden
you would get an interesting
conversation
uh if you said give us an example of
communism in the united states it would
get very interesting the real question
is is this just a low iq individual or
is this a brainwashed individual
or is it both in some way
um here's one last one just to show you
the craziness some guy
said he was there to deliver legal
documents to trump to help trump i don't
know what the documents are supposed to
do let's see
okay
our it says you are the 46th president
period says our lord dear mr president
donald j trump i have come to this
deliver legal documents to you so that
you can give them to your legal team
period
our king jesus christ has spoken to put
you back in your office at the white
house now it's funny are they legal
documents or are they religious
documents if it's jesus who has spoken
to put trump back in the white house why
is it even a question of legality like
isn't isn't jesus more powerful than
legality
sincerely rich thomas afterwards i had
legal documents oh
here
to put president trump back in office
now well he does watch us so that's okay
mr trump
look me up i have the documents i'm here
at the rally
i'm waiting to deliver king jesus says
it's time to deliver are you hearing me
absolutely there's a real okay so king
jesus there says it is time to deliver
i don't know uh what we make of this
what i do know is it's really hard to um
reorient these people to reality
whether it's hard because of a just
limited cognitive capacity
whether it's hard because of
brainwashing whether it's
you know
i'm not saying it's mental illness but
whether it's some kind of emotional
imbalance
um it's very tough to fix what we just
saw
let me know your thoughts we'll take a
quick break and be back after this